Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you for joining us for our 91st episode!
BAU BAU!
91, oh my gosh.
I'm sort of scared.
Moco-chan, by the way, I'm not scared of your froggy voice.
Moco-chan's not sick, she just has allergies, right?
It's just allergies, okay?
Have a howl of a BAU BAU!
Moco-chan's still really really allergenic.
A witch caught you and put a curse on you.
Orange is our cheese.
BAU!
BAU BAU!
To explain for any new Ruffians joining us or any Ruffians who are rather forgetful, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, Monday, aka FUWAMOCO!
Hosted by us!
FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Moco-chan is always cute!
It's fuzzy.
Just a little fuzzier than normal.
This is just a limited edition, Moco-chan.
Limited time flavor.
Limited time flavor
BAU!
Moco-chan.
Ruffians.
I think there's been another Pero Sighting.
Moco-chan, do you know the secret to that?
There's no more Pero Sightings.
Why?
For the Ruffians to not keep their eyes open.
They need their eyes open.
Where did you see Pero this time?
De-den!
That's a surprise.
Pero's sleeping in a coat pocket.
Pup's kinda happy.
I don't know, that's really nice of you to let him sleep like that.
Nice, but... Are you sure you're just going to work all day long while he sleeps in your pocket like that?
Like a big lazy bones or something?
Well, he only has two bones, but... Very lazy bones.
Can you still call him lazy bones?
Yeah.
Lazy bones.
BAU!
He's stealing your body warmth.
Yeah.
You know?
That's not good.
Are you okay with that?
Hi!
He's gonna get all comfy and be like, Oh yeah, this Ruffian is hot!
No.
BAU BAU.
Moco-chan, why is your voice so funny like that?
You sounded just like Pero.
Hi!
Yeah.
That's strange.
Are your ears okay?
Are your throat okay?
Yeah!
Like, too good!
Maybe letting him sleep would be safer, huh?
You know, if waking up Pero suddenly is anything like waking up Fuwawa... Huh?
Yeah.
Let him sleep, okay?
Huh?
I don't know why.
Yeah.
What are you playing, Moco-chan?
BAU BAU!
BAU BAU
You know we had Koyori-senpai over here as our first special guest on FUWAMOCO Morning!
It was so much fun!
And Ruffians, Koyori-senpai's English was so good too!
We were seriously impressed!
Were you just as surprised as we were?
I was so surprised.
But it was a lot of fun!
After FUWAMOCO Morning, you know, we got to chat a bunch and enjoy Pon de Rings together too!
And like we said too, we did it.
We tied the win with Mayonnaise!
Yeah, you know, FUWAMOCO's favorite, Pon de Rings, and Koyori-senpai's favorite, Mayonnaise.
Right.
Yeah.
Do you want to know what the result was?
Huh?
Oh?
Not your butt.
No.
When you put me on a pondering, okay?
No!
Oh!
Wow, the result was... Drama?
No.
It wasn't delicious, but it wasn't bad.
Just... Yeah.
Better without maybe and... Maybe.
It's good.
I would say it was good.
I couldn't recommend it.
Yeah.
But it's not the worst thing.
It was just...
Strange.
Thought a lot about it.
Hard to put into words.
Better than expected.
Maybe.
A little bit less.
It was sour and sweet but not in a gooey.
Not even a 4 out of 10, Ruffians.
2 out of 10, yeah.
It was just...
I don't even know what coriander is.
I finished my pondering by putting lots of coriander on top.
Sprinkle all over the place.
It was surprisingly really good.
Somehow I worked out.
Yeah.
I don't really know, it was just good.
Slancho?
I don't think that's the same.
It's not the same.
Yeah.
Boyander.
Hi!
Huh?
What do you mean I taste buds?
My Ruffians, if you don't trust FUWAMOCO's taste buds, it's time for you to try it then.
No, it was like a spice.
It had an interesting result.
Better than Miyo, right?
It didn't taste like, like, pakuchi.
No.
It was jive.
But, you know, it was just so nice to be able to talk to Koyori-senpai.
Yeah!
You know, we learned so many things from her!
Just, you know, we feel so, so thankful and happy and... Ruffians.
Oh my goodness, did we ask her so many questions?
You know what?
We weren't even asking her where she bought her furniture.
Maybe that's too many questions.
No.
Maybe.
But clearly Senpai was like, oh, I bought it for BAU BAU.
I don't know, she's probably like... So many questions!
FUWAMOCO... Well... They're fluffy and fuzzy, it makes sense.
Yeah.
Yeah, what a kind senpai.
Exactly right!
Yeah, but you know, we really really hope that we can have more collabs together soon.
Hopefully sing even more together, especially Moco-chan when you're no longer a froggy like me.
Yeah, but we did just become closer with Koyori-senpai!
We also got closer to her cat, Chikoyo!
Yeah, you know, Chikoyo's actually really shy and a little bit maybe scared of guests.
A bit defensive.
Yeah, so Koyori-senpai said that Chikoyo doesn't really open up to guests and
Usually just kinda high, but...
But!
I think we were the first guests that Chii-Koyo-chan liked so quickly!
Yeah, we were even able to pet Chii-Koyo-chan!
We played together a lot!
Chii-Koyo-chan was purring and being naughty and all cute, wondering, oh, where's Chii-Koyo's pond buildings?
Hi, where's Chuu?
We had such a good time together!
You'll be terrified of us, Chuu!
Hi!
Actually, Moco-chan.
I didn't tell you, but I found Chikoyo-chan's fur on you today.
Hi.
It was longer than your fur.
Oh, that's probably Chikoyo-chan.
Was I asleep?
I saw it on your back.
BAU BAU!
Maybe it'll be Koyori-senpai's turn next time.
Maybe.
We'll have to do even more off-vlogs together.
But not just a collab with Koyori-senpai.
But we also did another thing.
Something new.
Just the other day.
And that was Holodorou Kids' Wiki Time Explore!
BAU BAU!
It was together with those senpai.
Because maybe it might be a little bit confusing for maybe Ruffians.
Not too sure, but DOROKE!
It's sort of like a cops and robbers kind of game in my house.
And FUWAMOCO!
We are the robbers trying to escape from hollux with the police.
Yeah, we had so much fun!
Right?
It was great, right?
We weren't able to stream our practice, but
Actually, when we weren't able to practice a little bit the other night before the event, I was really worried that it wouldn't do well.
Because you know, I couldn't gather any amazons, and I couldn't do anything.
It was a bit rough, huh?
Yeah, I didn't expect you to cry a little bit.
It's not that big of a deal.
I wanted to help.
But!
For the actual game yesterday, Moco-chan managed to escape both times!
Both rounds!
And you were the MVP!
Everyone's hero!
I helped everyone escape, you know, by releasing them with the computer from the jail.
I did my best to help
Everyone escape and then make it to victory together as a team!
Fuwawa, I'll take you!
You got MVP too, right?
I did!
A different kind of MVP though.
I got...
MOST CAPTURED!
Fuwawa and Aoki, we both got captured the most.
But it's okay though, because Moco-chan, I had you, right?
And you were able to get me out of jail, too, right?
I was there, so it's okay.
But we had lots of fun together with our senpai.
I think there was so many really fun and silly moments too.
So please check it out if you haven't, Ruffians!
This also marks our very first two POV streams ever!
So we hope that you'll
BAU BAU!
Well, on top of that, just a few hours ago, we were actually live on the official hololive channel together with Nodokaisha as guests on her program, Holo no Kyuujitsu Kakko Kaeri!
You know, we were really, really happy to be invited to her party and everything.
I think we were the first hololive English members on Honno Kirititsu.
Right.
But, you know, it was just so much fun getting to chat together.
And through the whole push-up, we gathered a bunch of different fun things to be able to do together that you wanted to see us do.
Yeah, you asked!
Yeah, and, uh,
Shiritori Drawing.
But it was fun!
It was a success!
There was a BAU BAU speed test, which we won't talk about the results because FUWAMOCO, we won, we won, right?
No sore puppies here.
You know, we talked about what it's like moving to Japan.
We got to share Nodoka-san's favorite Japanese food together with us!
Finally, there was a very silly FUWAMOCO attempt at some
Did I count as an account?
I don't know, you'll have to check how it went, Ruffians.
I don't know about that.
FUWAMOCO!
We went home with many many PONDORINGS!
Right!
It was two boxes.
Right.
We got to share them with everyone!
So we didn't go home with two boxes.
We shared them, okay?
Yeah.
It's so nice to talk, but... I don't know.
How do you feel about FUWAMOCO-chan?
I think it went really well!
It was fun!
But I think rather than being on an official stream with Moco-chan, it sort of feels like we just went to a sweets buffet together.
Right!
We just kept on eating and eating!
Ruffians!
What happened to don't feed the dogs?
Huh?
BAU BAU.
But we're really really really thankful for all the kindness from the staff and their hard work too, you know?
And, uh, you know there was the ASMR too, Moco-chan.
How do you think that went?
There's a lot of happy Ruffians out there!
And that makes me happy!
But, uh...
Don't misunderstand.
Misunderstand!
No!
That wasn't our first ASMR, okay?
Okay, the first ASMR starts now, Moco-chan!
Go!
Moco-chan becomes a dinosaur ASMR?
Yeah, first ASMR, still not quite yet, huh?
Yeah, I guess that means it's yet to come, huh?
So, Ruffians, please look forward to it, okay?
That's the first time we said something like that, huh, Moco-chan?
BAU BAU!
But, but, but!
There was also some big news!
You know, I keep on talking about this Holo Plus app, but Ruffians maybe are not too familiar with it.
Wow.
The big news is that there's a global version of the Holoplus app in development right now!
Yeah.
And you know, together with the Holoplus app, you can get all the latest news about your oshimen and hololive as well, and interact with other fans too!
It's in Kool's Beta right now, but please look forward to it.
More updates from it in the future, okay?
BAU BAU!
Hi!
You know, but Golden Week!
The holiday week in Japan has just started!
And, uh, Ruffians!
Maybe you've been a little bit busy, but have you had a chance to look at our new schedule?
Because on it, you know, it's really packed.
There's a lot of exciting things happening, but tomorrow we have a big off club.
We're gonna be doing an off club with Marine-Senchou-senpai!
And we're playing Touhou Mountain Abyss!
BAU BAU Touhou Fujimoku!
What are we doing with Moco-chan?
Marine-Senchou-senpai, is she playing?
No!
Well, last time, you know, Moco-chan, you did pretty well playing FUWAMOCO.
We got a bit stuck, but this time, Mari-senchou-senpai, she's going to help mentor us, Moco-chan in particular, until we beat
Until we get to the end.
That's crazy, right?
I'm so nervous, but I'm excited!
Yeah, Marine-senpai, she's crazy good at doing it.
I know.
There's been a lot of times where I'm like, how?
How is she doing this?
This is amazing!
Yeah, we so can't believe we get to do an all-club together at her own place!
And it's our first collab, you know, in general.
Right.
We're going to do our best, Ruffians, but who knows how long Moco-chan could take.
Yeah, we could be there for a long time.
Ruffians!
Is there anything you want us to ask Marine-senpai or, you know, those kind of things?
You might have a good amount of time if Moco-chan's not too great at Touhou this time, huh?
You won't be doing it on purpose, right?
No!
Play poorly so you spend more time with Marine-senshu-senpai!
Ruffians!
Huh?
I don't know, Ruffians.
If you were to go to Marine-senshu-senpai's house, what would you do?
BAU!
What color?
Color of the bedroom walls.
Will you sleep together?
Why?
Toho?
I'm pretty sure you need your eyes open when playing Toho.
It's not a sleepover, okay?
You have to play Toho.
Ask her to do a Pikachu voice.
Moco-chan!
Pikachu voice, please!
Pikachu!
Actually, that went pretty well.
Smell her hat!
Okay!
How you wash a hat?
I don't know, I'll have to ask Marine Senpai how many times she's washed her hat.
We might put her on the spot, but we can't help it!
The Ruffians want to know.
Hi!
Well, there'll be lots of things to do and ask.
Hopefully, Moco-chan, you can clear it.
Otherwise, maybe we'll be guarding Marine-Senchou-senpai's house from now on, huh?
Wish me luck!
Okay!
FUWAMOCO!
Playing with an eye patch on.
The real experience.
Maybe that's the secret.
Pirate!
BAU BAU!
Have a hugfest with Mari!
It was nice because Koyori-senpai, she give us hugs.
Moco-chan also hugged me.
Nice and fluffy, right?
BAU BAU!
Maybe we get pirate hugs.
It's up to Mari-senchou-senpai.
But Ruffians, it's the start of a brand new week, and that means it's time to challenge ourselves to something new!
Which means, Moco-chan, you're gonna be challenging yourself to some natto!
Ruffians, you remember what natto is by now, right?
BAU!
Natto is a common breakfast food in Japan.
Slimy, stinky, uh, smelly.
Yeah.
But it's really good for you and that's why Moco-chan-
That's right, Moco-chan!
She's gonna do her best to eat some natto!
Especially because, you know, Ruffians have been saying natto's really good for your throat and everything, too!
Where is it?
Oh, it's just right over here, Moco-chan, but... Last week, you remember?
I was a wonderful big sister, and I ate a natto for you, right?
I can't remember.
So this time, I thought, you know, I got...
That's why it's in a really big bowl this time.
Because!
Ruffians!
Moco-chan is going to be eating this special kind of natto!
It's really, uh... It has a bit of a different smell.
The beans are really big.
Actually, there's about eight of them.
They're kind of round.
FUWAMOCO is very nice.
Moco-chan, do you know what this natto is?
The variety.
It's the pondering variety!
Extra healthy type.
Made by the farmers at Mister Donut.
Yeah.
It's not because Fuwawa eat all the natto.
No!
Moco-chan!
I think this will make you feel all better, right?
I still have one bean left.
One bean?
You can't eat it all.
Just one bean.
Moco-chan!
Hai!
It's a talent so you know.
Oh no.
My fingers are sticky.
It's sticky.
How does it smell?
Really good.
What is before you eat?
Don't eat it yet.
Wait, Moco-chan.
Before you eat it, let's say thank you to the farmer.
That miso tofu went really hard to make it.
And then dip it in the glaze.
And then package it up.
And make sure it gets to our paws.
Okay, Moco-chan.
Say thank you, Moco-chan!
Say thank you.
Thank you.
Okay, Moco-chan!
BAU!
BAU BAU!
Moco-chan, you like that challenge compared to nothing?
I think that makes sense.
Well... It was a challenge.
A challenge.
I guess you can call anything a challenge.
You know, maybe something that's really happy one day is harder next day.
So let's do it again!
No!
No, next week is not done!
Next time, okay!
Ruffians, please make sure you know it's a new week!
Maybe step outside of your comfort zone and try something new and aim for the stars!
And you'll end up somewhere.
BAU BAU!
We're cheering for you!
FUWAMOCO-chan, let's head to our regular corner sound.
Today's Doggie of the Day is... De-den!
It's me!
Stunning eyes!
Hi!
Mia is this Ruffian sister's doggy.
But super cute.
Look at my nose.
Those ears.
Hi!
Oh, kinda look what?
Like my ears, Moco-chan?
I don't know.
No, actually I feel like this Ruffian's name.
Oh, great.
It's sort of fitting for Mia too.
Oh, yeah.
Mia kinda looks like a nice couple.
Oh, great team with
A bunch of milk in it too.
But I guess also with zoomies too!
Okay, see you with zoomies.
Moco-chan, how do we think me about BAUs?
Let me power up, okay?
Okay, power up.
BAU BAU!
I hope Mia's BAU BAUs are a bit more contained than that.
Mia's four years old next month, but you know, she's a husky and she's going to zoom around like a husky no matter how many years old she is.
So I hope that it'll be a good zoomy buddy together with her and play with her lots too.
Maybe you can throw that ball, and she can chase after it, and then she can throw the ball, and you can chase after it!
A good buddy.
BAU BAU!
And next for today, I went on a walk!
We have... De-den!
What?
A big fish!
FUWAMOCO Morning!
I love it when you can kind of do that and discover something so cool that you wouldn't see normally.
But, but, the fish!
The fish though!
Please tell me you gave it a little bit of a pat pat too.
You know, usually it's not okay, but...
BAU BAU!
A peaceful garden and a big fish.
This sounds like a good balance.
BAU BAU!
And next we have our Question of the Day!
We have... De-den!
FUWAMOCO!
You saw the streams playing Bunny Garden by Pouka and Miko!
Are you interested in that game?
FUWAMOCO wa bunny garden ki ni natteru?
Bunny garden, huh?
Bunnies are cute!
Bunny girls are cute!
I don't know, maybe if they sold us cakes and not drinks instead?
Maybe, you know?
If they actually said pyon pyon!
Or a better yet!
Nyam nyam!
Fuwawai.
Isn't that just Nekopara-chan?
BAU BAU!
Playing Twister together does look fun, though.
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for all your submissions today, for your parasoids, your questions, your walks with doggies.
And don't forget your FUWAMOCO groups as well.
Please use the hashtag FWMCMORNING.
We're always waiting, okay, Ruffians?
So, if something
If anything cool happens, please let us know and we'd love it if you could be a brand new part of tomorrow!
Or the next day's FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Well, we have our next stream coming up.
In a few hours, we're gonna be playing Donkey Kong Country 2!
We just started playing.
We're playing on the original hardware.
It's been a little tough, but...
Definitely a lot of monkey business going on.
We hope you'll join us, Ruffians.
Especially if you could hold our paws, that would be good too because the last boss was hard.
That was the first boss?
Second boss?
Hard for you.
Not for me.
We did it together.
BAU BAU!
E.T.!
Did I say 4 p.m.?
4 a.m.
P.T.!
We're gonna be doing our OSU!
collab together with Mari-sensei and Chousen-senpai!
No shoot!
No shoot when we're gonna end, so maybe, you know, if you're like, I can't wake up at 4 a.m., but maybe I'll wake up at 8 a.m.
Well, we might still be playing it together with Mari-senchou-senpai.
I'm hoping because then we can have more fun with Mari-senchou-senpai!
But it's not gonna be so.
We have other things you know we're gonna be playing.
Lethal Company together with Fubuki-senpai and Koyori-senpai.
Wonderful Company is BAU, but this time, Fuwawa, I'll be playing as well!
So, it'll be all four of us.
And then we also have content warning.
We're going to be making some viral videos together with Haachama-senpai and Poruru-oneechan too!
Please go out with Haachama-senpai!
I'm a little bit concerned at the videos we might be making.
I'm not too sure what to expect.
You have to join us, Ruffians!
And then on the weekend, FUWAMOCO's Minecraft journey will be starting as well, so we hope you'll join us.
And don't forget, we're also going to be doing some clubhouse games together with Watame-senpai for the first time, too!
There's so many exciting things!
And four guys together as usual!
Doggy Pack!
The list goes on and on.
Oh!
It was Shiori's birthday, too!
Yes!
It's a busy week.
It's golden week!
But we're really excited so let's have a super fun week, Ruffians!
And for Ruffians who are joining us through the archive today, we have it!
Here is your FUWAMOCO'd word!
It's BAU BAU BATTLE SCREAM!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
Thank you for joining us today for the 91st episode of FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Mofukoro!
BAU BAU!
Tem!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!